go you should read the text never mind
oh my god is that us yes wish sorry -
coming up the fillet they can sing the
mandolin uncomment this oh we're just
gonna do this week
don't touch a comma B we have to Revere
repair really do you even Englishman we
have this okay there's a range there's a
wrench inside this as well I got the
welder go over here and get the wrench
what are you doing to that place good
job Welding sorry one moment got it I
got it go back to get the rich cover me
okay I'll cover you by welding this
Michael user ah I can't go close oh I
was dying we lift you one job yeah well
we have to use a robot to repair those
areas I hate myself a little bit
everything now that we repaired the
cables we can you know one small step
for man Hannah
Jesus sorry beta static say that
to me
someone target is I can hear you I think
headquarters is talking to us oh we have
like GG a space that's I have a problem
okay you love yourself a lot I just
removed it I don't know why it's a giant
space fan I don't know what I'm doing
what do I do with it it's my space
weapon in King's Mimi aliens it's like a
final fantasy sword hey Pitts I'm your
biggest I am your biggest fan there's no
air in space you couldn't technically
find someone we're busy
[Music]
construct robot I accept what I it just
came out of nowhere
oh it is fully control them amazing I'm
too far away from the control unit damn
it oh we deployed them in the wrong
place hey babe remove this okay here we
go
I'm doing something Oh like my arm is
doing stuff yeah yeah yeah I removed it
now where do I go I can just remove
stuff yeah anyway why would I remove all
this stuff I don't want to probably what
they meant with that song if your robot
has run out of power damn it alright
well at least I can play with your face
now what stop pushing me oh thank you
thanks but I've been ru what you're
still welding yeah dammit
help not break them I'm try em I will
some I'm just stuck on top of a you need
to push me you need to push me I can't
party
w-w-w-w-w-w-wait now maybe push me cuz
I'm stuck here nice one oh you fat pipe
away oh I'm free there is the other one
- you pass ya beat my robot what there's
a ramp down there my robot ran out of
battery
are you [ __ ] serious okay now I can
finally finish this last one one hand
arm robot came before I picked the wheel
there robot
we actually did it I can't believe in 51
minutes why you have to go a mixing and
so accept acai and puke if he was never
seen again they saved the earth and
mankind from moon explosion the bras and
ladies were forever heartbreak but they
will find ever remember their gravel
array and for every peer to shed their
legacy lives on the end
[Music]